this is the weekend scramble and we've
got toilet clog er Walgreens ambush and
dinin - penis penis penis who say vagina
I like [ __ ] breasts guys are so
immature so the first one that we have
is there's this dude from Wisconsin he
was a serial toilet clog er he [ __ ] so
much like has a hobby like he was like
here we go
yep oh wait what which [ __ ] is this one
elementary school this boys 26 years old
let me guess because if I put my mind in
a cereal toilet clogger I would always
wear like four or five pairs of socks
and every time I go out with just stuff
the shoe size are you wearing just stuff
it in the hole bless you ha ha that's
cheating
really yeah you're you have to [ __ ] you
have to call you what [ __ ] do that he
didn't do that oh he didn't oh no so
this guy he used a plastic bottle to
clog these toilets and it was always or
not always but like usually always in
women's bathrooms why why so he says I
quote he could not explain this behavior
but simply that he would get very strong
urges to do this oh he's an addict so
the name is Patrick he originally faced
[ __ ] counts so counts of criminal damage
to property but 7 of the charges were
dismissed and so now he has been
sentenced to a 150-day jail term and 3
years of probation for clogging toilet
clogged in toilet and then he's gonna
get in trouble there because he's still
gonna keep he's like gonna clog another
toilet now he hasn't 0 darling you guys
didn't see a bunch of clogged toilets in
elementary school kids would the seat
mat thingy and grab the whole thing and
just stuff it's [ __ ] fun yeah I feel
like you guys were do that I cheat
everywhere I never
clogged the toilet yeah give him some
credit tip I'm sorry I'm more class than
that you know what I would do though I
like it in the paper towels wetting them
isn't going everyone see kids are
terrible I never knew how to do that
until I got out of school I just like
Sean on the toilet seat on the sea yeah
what no that that would happen though
when you go to public restrooms you
guide us squat
I definitely squat on top of the toilet
no I sit on it like do you do this like
I don't know I'm sorry about the chair
but do you like it
do you like squat like this how do you
go like you fall
my mom does that every single bath she
doesn't do that we've talked about this
a million she crab hovers every time he
doesn't do that have you ever seen the
bad in when she goes both of her feet
are planted we've seen mark you don't
look like who you you don't trust when
I'm [ __ ] I don't know what the
stranger next to me something like I
just think you some [ __ ] happens I know
your mom always does that and you could
see her [ __ ] 4-inch Skechers on top
of the toy does where you know exactly
she's the one that taught me she goes
you always do this at public bathrooms
she was younger more limber our sketch
is an Asian thing Bart know there's
people that I only saw that an Asian
establishments though bringing it back
to Steve bow oh yeah works like bubble
gums Asian thing no boba go alright so
now for Patrick here after like he will
serve 150 days in jail he will also gave
their $5,500 in restitution
with a hundred hours of community
service and he will not be able to
possess or consume alcohol or any
control system can you imagine the
police sting like they had to have a
whole ass operation to catch this guy
clogging a toilet with plastic bottle
yeah I'm just more impressed that it's
like okay this guy they go to like
Houston Texas and then it's like oh
they're clogged toilet and then like to
to like block Stander's into the clog to
it these are connected there's a
detective that's
following this case yeah what if this
guy is addicted to this behavior and he
sought help so he goes to groups and
then yeah I'm [ __ ] addicted to
snorting crack and all this [ __ ] yeah
and then he's like yeah I'm addicted to
cloggin towards like get the [ __ ] out of
here you making fun of us and so we
can't get help
oh right there's the FBI black-and-white
pictures of him with the water ball yeah
yeah he's like Bart
trying to open up and everyone thinks
it's a bit yes use a specific type of
water bottle yeah it's a half-filled
with the rapper taking off yeah there's
like one o'clock boy to go to then the
bottles different and it has a wrapper
look it's not this guy on the floor of
like all the water a lot of taxpayer
money dude okay they're saying that it
costs the city about two hundred dollars
to repair the toilet that's who's gonna
have a Netflix documentary about a
serial toilet clogging an investigation
it's like making a murder yeah it's like
Ted Bundy tapes and [ __ ] that's pretty
good looks so weird though like his um
his uh what his fine is a lot bigger and
a lot more expensive than other like
like more severe crimes I started after
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
I agree yeah there's damages so that's
why it would go to that but it's like
but like people who like like deal
illegal substances and like do horrible
more horrible things get fined like a
thousand dollars I'm like bruh they
should be like paying like twenty grand
for this cuz everyone has to use a
toilet and now people couldn't use it
like that's a [ __ ] fair necessity
dude they have to disincentivize people
from doing this yeah for sure because
the [ __ ] saying that he worked at a
temp agency and that at the temp agency
they realize that all the jobs that he
would go to this guy goes up where the
toilet gets clogged
yeah like doing what he hears that they
fixed it to he's like I hear a toilet
running ha ha ha
alright moving on to the next story
about 60 minutes
women they ambush a Walgreens in Philly
and just stole [ __ ] like they just did a
runnin grass my kind of flash mob
stealing ambush
oh six gears seven my Walgreens six
other things sixty on I will show you
the video now they wanted to get some
prescription shoes sixty they know that
they know that many people that's what I
was thinking like that's a lot of people
to agree to do something so stupid it's
a it's a flash dealing mom the Walgreens
do something to them that over both god
that's a lot of whoa that's [ __ ] up
man
no and in there is that like a whole
entire high school class they look like
they're in high school yeah yeah it's
like the whole senior class nah there's
way more people in there what the [ __ ]
is going on that's funny
cuz they had their satellites oh man
this sucks cuz I'll tell you this things
that an employee that's here - oh [ __ ]
they look like thirteen to seventeen
like or maybe even younger I'll tell you
for sure
I would I would have been a part of this
group when I was like 12 or 13 yeah this
is just stupid ah
I would I would have had a blast I could
never dude I know I wouldn't either so
there's not what I would have influenced
you to do it
I wasn't that easily influenced you just
need to go out so I wouldn't even know
you know I don't think so I never did
things I would like be [ __ ] up to
other people to be [ __ ] up [ __ ] up
to myself she probably the lookout she's
like [ __ ] I can't do this please please
come on [ __ ] never stole anything yeah I
did
that's true that's what they were doing
we're just deal well I remember stealing
what's that Claire's like four earrings
at the bottom now bottom one and then I
also stole a wallet from Macy's
now imagine stealing but like riot low
low-key like riot style stealing like
with your friends can't do it I mean of
course
good [ __ ] but when you're 13 I'm just
tapping into my 13 year old mine and I'm
like yeah this would've
that would have been doh damn I mean
like we used to run up to like there you
know like those drive-through dairies
and liquor stores and just do grab and
goes all the time you know I thought it
was the funnest thing on earth the rush
yeah and like people chasing you and
stuff for this specific thing like how
slightly concerned or just scared right
in the mouth of it I think we're good
now you sure it's the mindset he's
getting into the mindset of that they're
going through go buy stuff and puts it
back now he grabs she does from seven
other ones to rob them throws it in
there and goes back boy he's like those
Chinese people that looking at jewelry
they grab it and then they run but to
the mirror remember that prankster used
to like leave money and buy buy [ __ ] and
run away like you would order food and
you buy was there a reason why I like
that mob did that so I actually don't
know anything else about this story like
they don't tell us whether or not they
caught people they don't see why they
did it they all I'm telling you guys
like the motives for these things if you
just can't think too much about it it's
literally like one guy has a
brainstorming ideas you know be dope if
we just go run under and grab anything
we want and run out and they can't get
but you're safe in numbers right because
it's like no I'm just thinking oh
there's a my comments so many people I
know how there's so many idiots
no one said no I don't think I even know
one person I could get to rob anything
with me
not one you're not 13 I'm more
interested in like how like they like
cuz its own cuz it's like a Walgreens
it's like s'more small or like underdog
under like $20 things so it's like like
what if like the Walgreens was like
doing something to these groups of like
people were like I don't know you you
guys were not fun cuz you you don't know
you don't know how fun this is
but you're right though yeah there was
probably an [ __ ] yeah I feel like
dude it's like this room that got around
oh there's that guy that always works
he's a [ __ ] dick and everyone knows
why let's go here and [ __ ] his shift up
because like look it because like
watching the video like they aren't
grabbing a lot of things conscious just
yet
yeah so like some there might be
something some kind of legit reason yeah
too legit right reason yeah maybe they
just come from a very bored party no we
need a spicy huh that's true it's like
Lord of the Flies though if you get a
bunch of kids together now don't really
grow up with much rules or they don't
give a [ __ ] like we cost a lot of that's
my thing is the mindset dude it's just
[ __ ] kids yeah big [ __ ]
I mean like this happens in riots this
happens in like all the takes is one
person to throw something and now
everyone's done its mob mentality you
know there's really no motive or reason
behind all especially if they're 13 is
16 like if my friends were like hey
let's [ __ ] burn down this Shack I'm
like okay I was [ __ ] dog I was like
the more crazier the better yeah and
that's how people get into crazy
situations and they need to keep chasing
that adrenaline all right and on that
note to our last story now there were
these two guys these two men who are
trying to do a dine and dash in Florida
and it actually ended up going really
really bad because they kinda
accidentally kidnapped the waitress what
how do you accidentally people just
[ __ ] taking [ __ ] and running these
days huh oh you think you thought it was
as homey like so let's say like uhm it's
me and hit me impart we're gonna dine a
dash and I'm like alright man you better
do this yeah but then Bart you know he
always has the P last minute alright
when you're not on the board well wait
then I don't hear him go I'm gonna go
pee and then the waitress comes on Mike
let's go and then I grabbed the wrong
arm so what ended up happening here so
this is a 46 year old man in a 27 year
old man oh right
they were friends they were yeah I know
it's really the same thing so they were
dining at this restaurant in Miami and
then so when they were trying to leave
without Diablos nose like Ron parada
dominicana don't mimic him food I guess
so then as they were trying to leave the
restaurant without paying that's when a
waitress who was serving them caught
them trying to leave so she followed
them out to the parking lot and then she
ended up hopping into the driver's seat
with the car door still open and with
her feet resting on the pavement stop
them from leaving oh I get it and then
that's when the situation escalated to
the point where one of the guys just
grabbed her and brought her in all the
way oh [ __ ] and then that's when this
other dude is like he got in the
driver's seat and drove off and she was
like begging and pleading to be let out
technically kidnapping yeah so they did
kidnapper
for like a block for a few blocks
because then that's when they dropped
her off was inside the car she called
911
lady would you try to find a safe place
to spot there's no shoulder there's no
altar this was gonna be very dangerous
if I drop you off here yes the next
woman one of the guys use a beer bottle
to restrain and threaten her oh so then
that's when someone else at the
restaurant noticed that she was gone
something they also call no no one they
were able they stopped the guys for over
a traffic stop they pulled what the [ __ ]
is going on anybody seen our waiter so
then the concepts was they over traffic
stop and then so that's when they found
out everything and they both have been
charged with kidnapping
I hope those frijoles were worth a [ __ ]
how much was a bill I don't know -
stupid guys he's got sass energy dude
thank ek he's in [ __ ] mode he's like I
don't give a [ __ ] Guyana leppe is biting
his lower lip I think that's just his
lip dude he's got that he's got no lower
lip he's got that turtle like he looks
like a turtle beep this photo like
weight which was 27 which is 46 when
adults dine and dash I'm just like how
[ __ ] up is your life yeah what's so
bad that you like you're like [ __ ]
Aladdin and you steal a damn Apple you
[ __ ] pathetic [ __ ] you street rat
yeah I'm like you're that broke like
come on dude even homeless people can
eat but I've seen homeless people in
restaurants I know
Oh having a good ol meal it's also sucks
cuz the waitress I think has to cover
the bill right yeah that's really yeah
yeah yeah it's like your responsibility
or some [ __ ] I don't know if that's like
that for every Russian ah but there's a
lot of restaurant I know it's not their
fault and that's why the waitress went
outside yeah if that is true why she's
clinging on the back of the car dude
please I gotta make Rick yeah she's like
giving my 27 dollars he [ __ ] yeah that
that policy makes it unsafe it should be
like the retail places where it's like
so much shoplifting like don't walk out
we're like don't go after them the store
maybe they're scared of like waiters and
waitresses hooking up too many friends
for free I gotta be honest that that
always bothered me the whole thing we're
it's like if you see something like
somebody shop with you from wall don't
go after them and you're the employee
there I think those stories are sick
when the employee goes and goes after
these people like I always like I was
like that growing up I don't know what's
like a liability thing because then if
you because you're technically on the
job so if you get hurt on the job then
they're gonna have to pay way more money
for hospital bill all that I know but
that's why you know when you're a kid
and [ __ ] you think about being a hero
and all stuff and like and you're like
man I want to do something sick and like
help-help this store you know stupid
[ __ ] good American boy tricky [ __ ] him
you always want to be the guy that like
clotheslines of guys is wrong I am I
don't want to be that guy but that's I
like it yeah there are some great videos
of like target loss prevention guys like
full-on
tackling people who are holding like big
screen TVs I got a buddy who used to do
he called it LP because he's a [ __ ]
loser he's like you know what I did LP
we're doing Oh what the loss yeah but
they gotta call it LP because it's like
you'd like hell agency like long against
me I yeah so yeah it's always these
wannabe cops too but he had he has like
like a highlight tape almost like how if
you're in football they would have a
highlight reel of you he made a
compilation of loss prevention of his
best tackles in full no
like mommy cook they would dive on these
guys it's like always him like basically
full-blown like reaching his body out
diving on a guy and then like wrapping
him up is what he called it that's a no
blart [ __ ] yeah right then he apprehend
the suspect and as he's walking back he
looks at the camera pretty sure that
it's somewhere
did he ever just like like 12 years
prematurely like do something that
wasn't even gonna happen oh that's funny
spots a receipt at the last second he's
like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I may be
[Music]